(audience cheers and applauds)
- You are so cool.
- Thank you. So are you.
- You don't have to hide
that chain.
It's so cool.
- No, I do.
The sound people told me to make sure
- Oh, 'cause it'll hit.
- it doesn't bang the microphone.
- Yeah, I know.
Oh, your accent's coming out.
Like, "Microphone."
So, you're from Australia,
do they do Halloween in Australia?
Do you get into it?
- No.
We have no Halloween.
- What?
- Yeah.
- Bah! Humbug.
Wait, what?
- Yeah. Not at all.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
- Yeah, what?
Why?
- Not even a little bit.
I'm not sure.
I think maybe a stranger
danger kinda thing.
Like, you're not really trusting.
- You know, it is really weird
- It's bizarre.
- because I let my kids go,
and then, until I became a parent,
I switch out their candy at home.
'Cause I'm-
- You have no idea.
- Because I don't trust humans.
I know that sounds so sad, but.
- Would you?
- Yeah.
You just never know.
And then people scare you
on the news, whatever.
So you have crazy cool
wildlife in Australia,
but you have a lot of
wildlife at your place
in LA as well, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
Because everybody's always
telling me, you know,
Australia's got crazy, you
know, bugs and spiders,
and at my house, I used to live
right by the Hollywood sign,
and I had a baby
rattlesnake in my backyard
- Oh.
- that I had to kind of,
you know, I put on these
micro, like oven gloves,
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- and I had like a pole.
There's this video of me
fighting this rattlesnake
(audience laughing)
out my house.
And then also up in the mountains,
rest in peace, but we
had this mountain lion,
who was 20 something years
old and his name was P-22.
- [Audience] P-22.
- P-22. Shout out.
- Aw.
- Yes.
Rest in peace. What a beautiful creature.
- Yeah.
- Just walking around
the Hollywood sign.
- I know. See, I have a ranch in Montana.
We have mountain lions,
and I always catch 'em on my trail cams.
They're so beautiful.
- Sure do.
- I don't wanna see one hiking.
- No.
(audience laughing)
- They tend to run away from you.
But I think when they get older,
they get a little different.
They get a little-
- Yeah.
Well, this one's kind of buff too.
- Yeah. Oh, so are the ones on my land.
- Yeah.
- They are well fed.
- That's beautiful.
(audience laughing)
- They cross by the camera
and I'm like, "Please, dear God,
never see me in person."
(Jacob laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
- But they're beautiful. I love it.
But there is a lot of wild and coyotes.
There's a ton of stuff
in LA.
- There's different stuff.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay. So I have to tell everybody this.
I don't know if you know this,
but I found this out about you.
You're quite the photographer.
- I like to take pictures, yeah.
- I like to take pictures
and I'm not good at it.
But you're really good at it.
So you have photos of traveling.
I wanna show everybody this.
- [Audience Member] Wow.
(audience exclaims)
- I mean, I just love the shots you do.
And there's so many.
We're gonna show more.
So like, what is this?
It's obviously a different form of selfie.
(gasps) I love this one.
- Yeah, this is me and my mom in London.
- [Audience] Aw.
- [Audience Member] Woo!
- I love it.
- Four or five years ago,
I think.
- And that camera is not brand new,
you know?
- No.
(audience laughing)
It's a Rolleiflex.
I'm not sure when it's from,
but it's got this little...
It's boring.
It's a twin reflex lens thing.
- It's not boring.
It's so cool.
- It is cool.
- It's something I would buy
and go, "I'm gonna use
this," and then I don't.
(audience laughing)
- It's weirdly simple.
It's not too hard.
- Yeah. Okay, yeah.
Well, I heard that music
actually helped you
with your accent, like
breaking your accent.
'Cause I feel like that helps me whenever,
I grew up singing classical music,
and it helped me take out the twang
- Right, yeah.
- whenever I sing,
so I can put it in and take it out.
- Yeah. You don't really have one.
- When I talk, I do.
(Jacob laughs)
- "When I talk, then I..."
- Especially if I'm tired or drinking.
- Right.
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
But really hits home then.
But, no, but I heard that
music actually helped you,
like break your accent, right?
- Yeah.
I listened to a lot of Eminem,
- Oh.
like a terrible amount of Eminem.
- So you sound like a tough American
when you talk.
- It was like Detroit.
- Okay,
- You know, I have a big
sort of twang to it.
And I still love that man so much.
I feel more and more
I have to thank him so much, you know,
for getting rid of the-
- He's incredible.
- Yeah.
I'm a huge fan as well.
- Yeah, I just found it interesting,
to break your accent,
you listen to Eminem.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Like, you're coming into
your auditions very aggressive.
(both laughing)
So what other artists do you like?
What do you listen to?
- Right now, I mean, Bon Iver is my
- Oh.
- number one, you know,
- Yeah.
- favorite thing to listen to.
The National.
I listen to a lot of
David Bowie at the moment.
- Yeah.
- But I have this thing
with David Bowie.
It's like overrated, underrated.
Like, he's so rated,
- Yeah.
- but then you kind of go back
and you listen to the music
and you're like, "Oh, my
God, it's really good."
- It's artistic.
- But it sounds silly though
to say like, "David Bowie is
really good at doing music."
- Yes. But, no, you're kind of right.
You hit something there.
Because people know his name and people...
I was introduced to David
Bowie from the "Labyrinth."
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
It's the coolest thing ever.
- Huge "Labyrinth" fan.
- It's amazing.
And that's how I got
to know him, but I know his
name more than I knew his music.
And then when I got into music,
I just started really
delving into his catalog.
I get what you're saying.
He's got an incredible catalog.
- He's like an artist just across
- Yeah.
- everything, you know?
- Visual, audio.
- Yeah, everything.
- Everything.
- Do you collect records?
I collect vinyl.
Way too much.
- Right, yeah.
I hear that you actually know about it.
- It's stupid. Yeah.
- I don't know anything about it.
- A vinyl?
- No. I have a lot of them.
- Oh.
- But I'll go to a Goodwill
and just buy a random ballet
jazz thing or something,
- Find.
- and then you listen to it and you find-
- But it's kind of an interesting
way to find music again.
- Yeah, you find stuff that
you probably can't even find
on Spotify and stuff like that.
- Yeah. That's the way
I found Ann Peebles too.
Do you remember the Missy Elliott song?
You're way too young.
♪ I can't stand the rain ♪
That song, whatever.
- [Audience] Woo!
So, Ann Peebles is the original singer.
I didn't even know
it was sampled.
- Right, right.
- I didn't even know.
- That's where you find.
You find all these,
- And then you find out.
so many Kanye West ones that you find.
- Oh, yeah.
- Like, so many.
- Sample King, yeah.
- So many references.
And then Bon Iver, same thing.
It's really incredible.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(audience cheering drowns out Kelly)
- As Elvis and your new
Sofia Coppola-directed film
"Priscilla."
(audience applauding)
So tell us, obviously the
movie is about Priscilla.
- Mm-hmm.
- That's the title.
But what else is going on in the movie?
- I mean, it really is about Priscilla.
It's Graceland through her eyes.
It's everything is her experience,
which is my sort of favorite
part about the film.
- Yeah.
- And it's Elvis
through her eyes, which is an Elvis
that I think a lot of people
- Yeah, that's interesting.
- haven't seen before.
- Yeah.
- It's super exciting movie,
strangely enough for a movie
that's very quiet and gentle.
- Yeah. So I heard this, about Sofia.
Did she try and raffle you off
to get money for the budget?
Like, what?
(Kelly laughs)
- You know, I think-
- I think there's laws against that.
- I think Sofia only heard
about that in the press as well.
- They took it and ran with it.
- Yeah.
- They never do that.
- No, they don't do that.
They always tell the truth.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- But, no, it was news to me.
But, I mean, I would've
done it in a heartbeat.
We did have a pickleball
sort of tournament running-
- I've never played pickleball.
- Oh, really?
- I know.
And it's a huge thing.
- It'll get you.
- That's kind of why I didn't start.
- Yeah. It'll creep up on you.
- I obsessed over things.
- Yeah.
- Are you good at it?
- I'm like capable,
(audience laughing)
you know?
- Are there partners in pickleball?
- Yeah.
- I don't wanna be your partner. Okay.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
I want someone coming in strong.
- No, no, no.
(audience laughing)
- Okay, so I heard that you had to get
an interesting haircut 'cause
you wore so many wigs, right?
- I did. Yeah.
I had this strange 1950s bowl cut thing
that could morph into his longer hair
and it was dyed pitch black.
So I kind of looked like I was
in Green Day or Fall Out Boy.
(audience laughing)
- Oh, my God. I love it.
- Because on the weekends
I had eyeliner from shooting all week.
- Guyliner. Yeah.
- Yeah. The guyliner.
And then it would sort
of run and I wouldn't-
- Then you'd looked like Alice Cooper.
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
I was walking around Toronto in the snow,
with this bowl cut, extremely,
you know, exhausted.
- I had the bowl cut when I was a kid too.
Ooh. It's not attractive.
- Oh, yeah?
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
Interestingly enough, it did,
you know, it carved out a
little personality, but anyway.
(Jacob and audience laughing)
This isn't your first
musical role though, right?
- No.
- Did you grow up
doing musical stuff?
- My first role ever
was a musical, and I
played the Cat in the Hat
in "Seussical the Musical."
- Yes.
(audience exclaims)
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yes.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Look at how proud you are.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah. Right now, like this.
- Just so proud.
(audience applauding)
I love it. I love it.
I bet they knew Vin, you
know, from that photo.
They're like, "He's gonna make it."
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah. They might say that.
- Just the confidence. I love-
- I think they asked me to
leave the school after that.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- No. Do you believe in mentorship?
'Cause I would've loved,
I came in as a teenager,
and I would've loved to have someone
to bounce stuff off of.
Do you have any mentors in the industry?
- I mean, nothing so direct
'cause I kind of shy away from advice.
I'm kind of
- Yeah?
- I don't like being
told sort of what to do.
But I think, just subconsciously,
the people that I've worked with-
- Are you a Scorpio?
(Jacob titters)
- Dunno what that means.
- Okay. Oh, it's a-
- I'm a Cancer.
- Oh, you're a Cancer. Okay.
Okay.
- Little crab.
- I like it.
(Kelly laughs)
"I'm a little crab."
- Yes.
- No, I love that.
Okay.
I take advice only as advice.
- Yeah, I just don't wanna get married
to any idea or anything.
- Yeah.
I don't wanna get married. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
(audience cheers and applauds)
There we go.
That's great.
No, I do think that, 'cause
it's what makes you, you.
Your decision-making process. I get that.
I hear that you're also
a Jack Kerouac fan.
- I am.
- I feel like you're so young
for that, but that's cool.
- I feel like that's the only time
that you're supposed to
be a Jack Kerouac fan,
it's when you're young, and
then maybe when you're old you,
you can revisit.
- Yeah.
- But, yeah. Yeah.
I kind of found, you know, on
the road at the right time,
18, 19, you know, going
to America, leaving home.
You know, I've got fire on my feet
and, you know, I'm trying to
find the feeling in things.
So it was like a companion,
you know, novel to my,
sort of coming to America
and everything like that.
- Yeah. That was "Jane Eyre" for me
- Oh, yeah?
- That book changed me.
Yeah. That was just that.
I love that book.
'Cause I moved out to LA
before "Idol" or whatever,
and, yeah, I got very lonely.
Like, I can get lonely really quickly.
It's nice to have things like that.
- Yeah.
- Like give you solace.
- There's section in Kerouac's book,
'cause he's going and going
and traveling across America,
searching for his pal,
and sort of towards the end,
he's so sort of tired and weary.
And there's this one sentence
and it's highlighted in my copy of it.
And he said, "I wish I could see someone
that had known me for
more than five minutes."
And that's paraphrasing
it or something like that.
- Yeah.
- But that was the line
- Really deeply knew.
- that really kind of rocked
me from that book, you know?
This idea of having someone
that knows your soul
and movements, not just kind of
- Yeah.
- who you are or what you've
done or, you know, that kind-
- I had to train myself
to be good at small talk.
I was not, that was not my thing.
- Yeah. I'm not there yet.
- I'm amazing at it now,
but I had to train myself.
'Cause I'm deeply, I like
wanna know everything
and I wanna get in a real
conversation and know someone.
And that really hard for me to do.
- I just sort of will walk away.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- I'm in that phase.
- That's a nice approach as well.
- If you act strange
enough, people would like...
(Kelly laughs)
- He's odd.
You're like, "Yeah, I'll get away
if I'm odd."
- Yeah, you get away
if you're odd, you know?
- I love that.
Well, let's do another break everybody.
"Priscilla" is in theaters
nationwide starting this Friday.